Hello world,
it's to Raj and we're going to detect
who the intruder is in our security
system.
So say we've got a website and we're
monitoring all of this network data and
there's one guy,
one bad dude,
one bad own Bray who's trying to
break into our security system.
We want to find who this guy is.
And the way we're going to do this is
by implementing a machine learning model
called k means clustering.
And I've never implemented this before,
so I'm really excited and it falls right
in line with the rest of the stuff I've
been talking about in this series.
So let's get started. First,
I've got this little image to show you
what the algorithm looks like. This,
it's a five step process and this gift
kind of shows what that looks like.
We start off with data that has no labels,
it's just a cluster of unlabeled data.
And we don't really know anything
about the data other than the features.
We don't know what classes
the data belongs to.
That's what we're trying to learn.
And what the algorithm will do is
it will iteratively take this data,
this unlabeled data, and it will
create clusters from this data.
And we don't know what,
where these clusters are going to be.
The algorithm is going to help learn
where those clusters should be. Okay.
So,
and I'll talk about what these steps are.
Well let me define what this term is.
K means clustering.
This is one of the most popular
techniques in machine learning.
You see it all the time in Kaggle contests
and the machine learning sub reddit
everywhere. It's a very popular algorithm
and it's very easy, uh, more or less,
I mean more than other things
that I've been talking about.
So that's a good thing. But let's
talk about what we've learned so far.
What we've learned is that machine
learning is all about optimizing for an
objective, right? We are trying to
optimize for an objective that's,
that's the goal of machine learning.
And we've learned about first order
and second order optimization,
what's first order gradient
descent and its variance, right?
Where we are trying to,
if we were to graph the error of a
function versus it's weight values,
we want to find the minimum
of the function so that we
can find the ideal weight
value so that our error is minimized.
And to do that with grading dissent,
we compute the first derivatives,
right?
The partial derivatives with respect
to our weights using our error.
But for second order optimization,
we do the same thing except we compute
the second derivative that is the
derivative of the derivative.
And there's pros and cons to both.
And we talked about when you would use
one over the other and the previous
videos. But what happens, here's
the, here's the big question.
What happens if you don't have the label?
How are you supposed to
compute the air? Right? It's,
it's usually the predicted
label minus or sorry,
the actual label minus
the predicted label.
That's the air use it to compute the
partial derivatives with respect to each
weight value.
But if you don't have the label,
how are you supposed to compute the air?
And that's where unsupervised learning
comes into play. Specifically.
K means clustering. So I've got this
diagram here to show the differences here.
So there are two outcomes that
we could possibly want, right?
Either a discrete outcome that is some
contained outcome like red or blue or
blue or black or white or up or down
or not guilty or guilty right there.
These containerized outcomes,
binary outcomes,
not just binary cause it could
be more than zero and one,
it could be multi-class,
but outcomes that are containerized into
okay,
specific labels.
Whereas continuous outcomes are like time
series data where it could be a value
between two and three or between two
and 2.5 or between two and 2.25 and it
could just go infinity in that direction
of that, of that numerical interval.
Right?
So with supervised learning,
we learn how to do predict a continuous
outcome using linear regression.
That was our first video.
And then the next thing we learned
was how to predict a discrete outcome.
And we use logistic regression for that,
and that's when we have labels.
But if we don't have labels,
then we use clustering to
predict a discrete outcome.
That's what we're gonna do.
We're gonna predict a discrete outcome.
And by defining these classes for people,
it's these discrete classes.
And then we're going to find the
anomaly that is the intruder.
And so then for a continuous outcome,
you,
you'll want to perform dimentionality
reduction. And that's next week.
So we're not, we're not
there yet, but we'll talk.
We talked about this one and this
one and now we're going to talk about
clustering.
So let's keep going here.
So on supervised versus
unsupervised learning, what
are the pros and cons? Well,
for supervised learning it's more
accurate. I mean, you've got the labels,
of course, it's more
accurate, right? It's like,
it's like having training
wheels on your bike,
but you have to have a human who labels
this data or it's just labeled itself
somehow. But unsupervised learning
is more convenient cause you,
cause most data is unlabeled,
right?
You don't just have this neatly labeled
data like, oh this is this or it.
No, data is messy, the world
is messy, life is messy.
So that's what we want, ideally to
run our algorithms unsupervised.
But the problem is that these algorithms
are usually less accurate. Right?
But it requires minimum human effort cause
no one's got a label. These, these, uh,
data points by hand.
Okay.
So let's talk about how this algorithm
works mathematically and then we'll get
right into the code.
Okay?
And so what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to glaze over most of the code and I'll
write a few of the most
important bits. Okay? So
how does this work? So we've got a set
of points, right? So a set of points x.
And so what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
take this and I'm gonna make two copies
of it so we can see this Gif
while I talk about the algorithm.
So let me do this,
hold on just like that and put
that here and then put this here.
Okay.
So,
okay,
so the way this algorithm works
is
we've got a set of points, right?
I set of points x and then,
and then we define a value.
Kay and Kay is the number of
clusters that we want, right?
K Means Algorithm. That's where k comes
from. So we've got a set of points x,
all of our data points,
and we've got k that's our input.
And so we're going to say two,
let's just say two for now and we'll
talk about how to realize what the best k
value is. But let's just say two right
now. And so then once we have that,
we're going to place a set of
centroids at random locations.
How many centroidsK centroids.
So if we chose to for k,
then the centroids are just data points
that are just randomly plotted on the
graph.
Okay.
These are called centroids
because eventually they're
going to be the center of
each cluster that we learn. So the
center, so the centroid points are there,
k of them, and we just plot them
randomly. Okay. So we definedK ,
we have our set of data points and
then our set of centroids k of them,
and we just plot them randomly. Okay,
now what? Now here's the steps we do,
and we repeat them until convergence,
which is what we predefined
beforehand with threshold value.
So what we do is we say for each
point in the data set, so if,
let's say for we have 40 data points,
so for each point,
let's say for one of them we're
going to find the nearest centroid.
How do we do that?
Well,
we compute the distance between that
data point and and each of the central
points. So there's two, in our case
there's going to compute the distance,
the Euclidean distance between that point
and both of the centroid and isn't to
find the one that's closest to it.
And that's where this Arg
Min function comes in.
What is the minimum value
in this set of values?
So we're going to find the
shortest distance and that's
going to be our cluster.
So we're going to assign that
data point to the, to the cluster,
Jay or Jay is for the centroid that
is closest to that data points.
Okay?
So then what happens is we've got a set
of clusters now and we do this for every
single data point.
So every single data point will belong
to a cluster and that cluster will be
defined as a centroid point. That
is closest to that data point. Okay,
so that's the initial cluster
that's going to be defined.
Then for each of those clusters,
Jay,
we're going to take all of those
data points in that cluster.
We're going to add them all up and
then divide by the number of them.
And what is this called? It's called
the mean, right? Or the average.
So now you're getting to see where this
name comes from. Right? K means, right.
It all makes sense. I was
like, God, I love that. Okay,
so k means is the name of the algorithm
and so we find the mean point or the
mean value for all the points in that
Dataset and that mean is going to be
become our next centroid point.
Okay.
So we've defined centroids,
we've,
we've grouped our data points into each
of these centroids and then we will then
find the mean of all those values.
And that will be,
those values will be our new centroid.
So in our case there will be two, right?
So there'll be two new centroids that
we then plot and then we just keep
repeating the process.
So we go back to for each point acts
and for those new centroids find the
distance for all the closest data points
and it's going to be a new cluster.
And so that's what you're seeing here.
It's going to be a new cluster.
And then we just kept keep
repeating that process until when,
until none of the cluster assignments
change and then we're good.
So right. So that's kind
of how that works. And so,
uh,
right.
So we can also terminate the program
when it reaches an iteration budgets and
we'll say after, you know, x number of
iterations, just stop running. Right.
So then one of one great question that
I hope you're asking is how do we know
what value forK we should use?
Well,
it's very simple if we know what classes
we want to classify or how many classes
would you say that that's the value for k.
So if we know that we want
to classify people as either
a, from a certain region
or from a certain place,
then we'll just say like of these
three places, you know, Spain, Mexico,
and I don't know, Argentina,
random the countries,
well I guess those are on my mind.
Then we know that k should be three
because we have three countries that we're
targeting. But if we don't
know how many classes we want,
these are just unknown unknowns.
Then we will have to decide
what the best case value is.
And that can be a guess and check method,
but it's actually a smarter way to do
that. And it's called the elbow method.
So the elbow method is a very
popular method. Well you have to do,
you have to rub your elbow
and I'm just kidding.
So what happens is you've got this graph
here, okay. And it looks like an elbow,
right? It's got this elbow point
right here. So what you do,
and I've got this part in Javascript to
show you what this algorithm looks like.
I know Javascript, right? So here's what
it looks like. We perform. K means once.
So we,
so we define a set of key values between
let's say between one and 10 okay?
So that's a good starting point.
K could be either one cluster
or it could be 10 clusters.
Let's try k means for all 10 of those.
And so what we do is we perform k
means for all of those key values.
And then so that's what this is.
So for,
for as many k values as we have between
zero and 10 let's perform k means to
find all those clusters.
And then for each of the clusters,
let's find the mean value. And what is
the mean value? It is the error value.
So what is the distance between
the centroid and all of its points?
And that's going to be
the mean or the error.
And what we want to do is
we want to compute the sum
of the squared error values.
And so that's what this line is right
here, the sum of the squared hairs.
And so we say math dot pal,
which means square the data point
for each data point minus the mean.
So for every data point in ours,
in our Dataset,
we're going to take a data point
minus the mean value and square it.
And so what that's gonna do is if we were
to graph that for all of those number
of cluster values for all those k values,
we'll see that the sum of the squared
errors for each of those iterations of k
means makes this elbow like graph.
And what we want to do is we want to
pick the k value that is right at the
elbow,
right at that tipping point right here.
So it would be six in
the case of this graph.
And that is our optimal k value.
Okay.
Because after that there's very
diminishing returns. As you can see,
we want to find the minimal error value.
And we've found that for this k
value of six, the error is uh, at,
it's not at its smallest,
but at the point where it's everything
after that is just diminishing returns.
And we could say 10 or 12 or 14 but
then for computational efficiency sake,
we could just say six. So we don't
have to run that many iterations.
So we'll just say six. Okay, so that's
the elbow method. All right, so,
uh, three more points and then we're
gonna get started with the code.
So how is it, this is computer between
the centroids in the data points,
the Euclidean distance,
right?
We've talked about the Euclidean
distance for linear regression, right?
Euclidean distance.
It's a very simple distance formula.
You just take each of the data
points and then you say, uh,
x one minus x two plus c squared
plus y one minus y two squared.
And then if you have z values,
Z one minus z two squared and
the square root of all of those.
And that's the Euclidean distance.
And what that does is it takes two data
points and it gives us a scalar value.
And that is the distance
between all those data points.
So you can apply the Euclidean distance
to a multidimensional dataset where you
have, you know, any number of dimensions.
You just subtract the values
for each of those dimensions,
for each of those data points, uh, the
square, and then you find the square root.
Anyway, I'll show you the equation
when we get to it. But yeah,
the Euclidean distance and to answer
any questions about why the Euclidean
distance as opposed to
other distance metrics.
The answer is because k means technically
minimizes the within cluster variance.
And I know we haven't talked
about this term yet and we will,
but I'm just trying to
be very detailed here.
And if you look at a
definition of variance,
which I'll define more in detail later,
it is a,
it is identical to the sum of the squared
Euclidean distances from the center.
So in Euclidean space and because it
is identical to the sum of Euclidean
distances,
we use the Euclidean distance as our
distance metric as opposed to something
else like the Manhattan distance.
Okay.
So lastly or two more actually,
when should you use this?
If your data is numeric, and that means
if your features are numeric, right,
you have numbers for your features.
If you have a categorical feature like uh,
the shoe color, uh, or
true or false, a boolean value, you
can't really map that in Euclidean space,
right? These are, these are categorical
features. So, but if your data is numeric,
k means is your, is
your, is your algorithm.
It's also the simplest
algorithm you'll see.
It's actually a very simple algorithm.
And when we talked about the pseudo code,
it's a relatively simple algorithm.
And the advantage it has over other
techniques is that it is fast.
That's the real key value. It's
simple and it's fast. You know,
a quick and dirty clustering
algorithm. It's great for that. Okay.
And it really shines when
you have multivariate data.
So that is more than one
dimension. Okay. So lastly,
two other examples of God here.
One for fraud detection and then
one for m and ist without labels.
I know what that is possible and eyes
he without labels. Yes, it's possible.
Anything is possible.
So anything is really possible here.
So for credit card fraud detection and
for finding these labels for these, uh,
for these MSI is t images where let's
just say we don't know the labels.
Usually we know the labels.
Well,
let's just say we don't know the labels
and if we don't know the labels and it's
going to cluster the
images into what their,
what their respective clusters should be.
And those are clusters for ones and
twos and threes in terms of the image,
the images. Okay, so check
those other two examples out.
And now let's get into the
code. Okay, so I'm moving here.
I'm moving.
Okay,
so the first thing we want to do is we're
want to import num Pi for matrix math
map plot line to map plot
live to plot out our graph.
And then the animation module of
plotline cause we're going to graph,
we're going to animate some
graphs in a second. Okay.
So then let's take a look at our data
set. Okay. So where is our datasets here?
Our dataset is as what our
data set looks like. Okay.
So we've got two dimensions.
We've got two features in our dataset
and the feature on the left is how many
packets are sent per second.
And the feature on the right is
what's the size of a packet. Okay.
So what we're trying to do is we're trying
to detect the anomaly and that is a d.
Dot. Sir. If you know what ddosing is,
it's basically flooding a server with
packet requests until a server goes down.
So we're trying to see how many packets
are sent per second from this user and
then what is the size of that
packet. Okay? And then that's that.
Those are our data points and we have
a few of these data points. Okay.
So that's it. Just two features for our
data and we'll talk about, like I said,
dimentionality reduction later on.
If we have a million features,
how do we reduce it to two or
three so that we can visualize it.
So that's our dataset that
we want to load. Okay.
So then here's what we've got here.
This is the Euclidean distance.
Now this is the formula that I was
talking about. So given two data points,
p and Q, take each of the values.
So if it has, you know, Q,
it could be x, it could be
y, z take, he did the values,
subtract them to get the difference,
square it.
And then add them all together and
then square root, that whole equation.
And so that's what the sigma notation
to notes. It's a sum of a set of values.
We're starting at equals
one for end values.
Find the difference difference
between all the data,
all the feature values
in a data points squared,
and then find the square
root of all of that for the,
some of the sum of the
squared errors. Okay. Uh,
technically the sum of the squared errors.
Yeah, and that's Euclidean distance.
So that's a Euclidean distance.
And so now let's look at
the actual algorithm itself.
So what I've done here is
I've defined it's hyper,
it's hyper parameters, and then I'm
going to code out the algorithm itself.
Okay?
So four k means we've got a k
value that is a number of clusters.
And since we were just going to say too,
okay,
we have two clusters that we want
and then we have an epsilon value.
And the epsilon value is,
it's a zero. It's a threshold.
It's the minimum air to be used
in the stop condition. Okay.
When we want to stop training,
okay. When their air is zero.
And then we have our distance.
So what, what type of distance?
We want to compute the EUCLIDEAN
distance. Okay, so let's keep going.
Let me make it a little bigger. So what
we're going to first do is store this,
the past centroids in this
history of centroids list.
Now this is not really a part of
the algorithm. This is just for us.
So we can then graph how the centroids
move over time later on so that we can
visualize it. Okay? So then
we're going to say, okay,
the distance metric is
going to be Euclidean.
So we define it right here as this method,
that variable.
And then we set the data set.
So we load up that data set from txt.
We've got those two dimensions, right?
The amount of packets that are sent,
and then the size of each packet.
Okay? So we've got our data set,
we've defined the distance metric,
and now we're going to say, okay,
let's get the number of instances and the
number of features from our Dataset by
taking this shape
attribute of our dataset.
So our rows and our columns or rows are
going to be the number of data points we
have. And there are columns are going
to be the number of features we have.
So we want to store those two values.
Then we're going to define K
centroids, right? So like I said,
we randomly plot the centroids on the
graph and where they're going to be,
how many centroids they're going to be.
K centroids special k
the cereal. Okay. So,
um,
okay,
so we're going to say our Dataset is
going to be, we're going to say, okay,
so from our Dataset, how many clusters do
we want to find right? Chosen randomly.
So we're going to say size Kay.
So we're gonna find a random
number between zero and a
number of instances that
we have that that is a number of data
points minus one of size. K. Okay.
And so we're going to store that the,
the centroid values in this
prototype's variable, right?
So we've got our centroids and then,
uh,
we want to set these to our
list of past centroids as well.
So we're going to take those centroids
that we just defined randomly and set
them to our history centroids list.
So then we can just keep a copy of it
over time and we'll keep adding our
centroids that are calculated to this
history centroids list so we can graph it
later, you know, for our
own visualization. Okay.
And then we have our prototypes old list.
It's going to be initialized as
a bunch of Zeros. It's empty,
it's an empty vector or tensor.
And so that's going to keep track
of centroids every iteration. Right?
So we've got our prototypes, which is
our current and our prototypes old,
which is are the set of
centroids that we had before.
And those two are what we're going
to use for the actual algorithm,
the histories or the histories.
Centroids is just for us to see
how it changes over time. Okay.
And then we have one more list and that
is the belongs to list to store the
clusters over time.
The clusters themselves,
all the data points
contained in a cluster. Okay.
And then we have our distance method,
which is going to take
the current prototypes.
And then the prototypes old
and the distance between them.
And it's going to store that in
the norm. Uh, variable. Okay.
And then the number of iterations,
which we'll start up as zero. Okay,
so now let's go ahead and write
out this algorithm, shall we?
So we're going to say,
okay, so while the norm,
the distance is greater than epsilon,
where epsilon is zero,
in our case we're going to say,
well,
the number of iterations
we're going to add one,
cause this is our first iteration. We have
begun training our model. So we'll say,
okay, well the iteration is going to be
one. And so let's compute with enormous.
So given our prototypes
where we are currently,
let's compute the distance between those
prototypes and the prototypes that we
had before. And that's going to be our
norm. Then we're going to say, okay,
so for each instance in the Dataset,
so let's go through every single instance.
So we'll say,
okay,
well what is the index of an intense
and what is the actual value of that
instance?
Those are the two variables that we're
going to use to enumerate or iterate over
the data sets.
We'll say,
let's define a distance vector of size.
Kay.
So now it's time for us to define
what this distance vector looks like.
So we'll say,
okay,
so the distance vector is going to first
of all be initialize as a set of zero
values of size k. Okay. So it's uh,
it's going to be empty at first and
we're going to add value to it over time.
Okay. So we'll say, okay,
so for each centroid value,
we have our random centroid values,
right? We already computed the,
there's values randomly at the beginning,
right? So we're going to say, okay,
so eat for each centroid value.
Let me just make this a
comment for each century value.
So for the, for the prototype, and
there's a stored in our prototype,
so we'll say for each index and then
the actual value for the prototype,
let's go ahead and do this
for call of those prototypes.
So for each instance in our Dataset,
and then for each centroid,
so we have two nested for loops,
right?
And then for each centroid
and numerate prototypes,
we're going to say we want to compute the
distance between what do we have to do.
We have to compute the distance between
each data point and its closest and each
centroid.
So for every data point we went to
compute the distance between it and every
other centroid and we want to find the
minimum distance centroid that closest
centroid to it so we can put
it into that specific cluster.
So it was like compute
the distance between
x and x is the data point and centroid.
So we'll say distance vector is
going to be index prototypes.
So for the centroid value,
so here's what we're going to do.
We're going to compute the distance using
distance method between the prototype,
which is the centroid and the instance
value. So for all of those x values,
for all those data points,
we're going to compute the distance
and story and a distance vector list,
and then it's going to be indexed by
the index prototype. Okay? Uh, and then
we're going to do that for all of them.
So that's why we have a nested for loops.
So that's going to store all of those
distances in that distance vector method.
And then when we want to do is we want
to find the smallest distance and assign
that distance to a cluster. So we're
going to say, okay, what is the what,
what cluster does each disk does
each a data point belonged to?
And we'll say,
well,
we'll define it in his belongs to array
and define it by its index instance.
And so now we'll do that arguments that
where we'll find the minimum value for
between all those distance
vectors that we calculated. Okay.
Between all of those distance values and
we use the Euclidean distance that we
define previously in a, in
its own function. And so as
we were going to say, okay,
so we're going to store them all in
there and then we're going to say, okay,
so then we have a list
of temporary prototypes.
Those are temporary centroids because
we're going to update our centers in a
second and we want to save where we are
right now so we could store it in our
history list. So say we'll create, um,
a little
tenser right here and it's going to be
up sized k by the number of features,
right? Because that's the number of
clusters we have. And we're going to say,
okay,
for each cluster,
hold on for each cluster
and our k of them,
let's say. Okay, so for, for each
cluster and there are k of them,
let's go ahead and say, let's get
all the points assigned to a cluster.
Let's get all of those points assigned to
a cluster, right? So we're going to say,
okay, I'm just going to paste it in
for it cause it's a little faster.
We don't have a little bit left. Okay.
So for each cluster in their k of them,
we're going to get all the points
assigned to a cluster. Okay?
And that's what this, what
this uh, line does right here.
We're going to get all those points
assigned to a cluster and store them in
instances close. Okay? So those instances,
close contains all the data
points within a specific cluster.
And we're doing this for each
of the clusters, so, right.
And for each cluster k of them,
we're going to find the
mean of those data points.
And so now you get the
k means for k clusters,
compute the mean of the data points
in that cluster using n p. Dot. Mean.
So that is the average.
We add them all up and then divide by
the number of them for all of those
instances and store
that mean in prototype.
And then we're gonna that's
gonna be our new centroid.
So we'll add our new centroid to our
temporary prototypes list and we did that
so we can then take that
temporary prototype and assign
it to our main prototype
list.
Okay.
So then were the temporary prototype
variable acts as a buffer as well,
computing new centroids to store them
and then we can add it to our main
prototypes variable. And then we
have our history centroids list,
which will also append to just for us to
calculate this for us to visualize how
this centroids move over time later on.
And you'll see exactly what I
mean by that. At the end of this,
we were turned our calculated centroids
and that is at the end of our algorithm
and we have reached convergence and
then our history of centroids all those
centuries that we've calculated over
time and then belongs to which is the c,
the all the clusters or the where we
cluster all those data points and then the
index is going to be the cluster
that it belongs to that k cluster.
And so that's how we define all those
data points in a single cluster. Okay,
so that's it for the algorithm.
And then we're going to
graph what this looks like.
So in our plotting algorithm
we're going to say, okay,
well we're going to have two colors,
red and green for our central,
we'll define them here. We'll
split our graph up, bites,
acce access and it's actual plot.
And then for each point in our Dataset,
and we've got several points in our
data set, we're going to say, okay,
we want to graph all these points
by their cluster color, which we've,
which we're going to define.
So all the,
all the data points in one cluster are
going to be one color and all the data
points and another cluster are
going to be another color. Okay?
So then we'll get all those points
by looking in. D belongs to list,
okay? By its index, right? So for the
index, for each point in our Dataset,
get the instances,
those are all the data points that
belonged to a specific cluster and then
assign each data point in that cluster
a color and plot it its own respective
color, okay? And so
that's what we do here.
And then we're going to log
the history of centroids.
Remember how he said how we want to see
what the history of centroids that our
calculators are so we can check, see how
it changes. That's what we're doing here.
So in the history points list, we'll
say for each centroid ever calculated,
print them all out and then plot
them in their own graph. Okay?
So that's what's happening in the method.
And then we're going to
actually execute it, right?
We've written methods for
our K-means Algorithm.
We've written a method to plot out our
results and now we can execute these
methods.
So we're going to load our Dataset,
train the model on that
data where k equals two.
So we want to clusters and then it's
going to give us back our computed
centroids the history of all the centers
that were computed over time and in our
list of data points defined by
the cluster that each belongs to.
So we could take those three values
and then use them as parameters for our
plotting function. And that's going to
plot our results. And so when we run that,
we're going to get these
two clusters, right? So if,
if we didn't run our k-means algorithm
and we just plotted our data,
it would look just like this,
except there would be no color.
Cause we don't know what the clusters are.
But what happened was the
algorithm learned that the,
that the right clusters were red
and green for the, for these,
for these respective clusters.
And the blue points are
the central central points.
And so those are the centroids.
Okay.
And so over time what happens is, look,
here's, here's what I mean by over time,
over time,
what happens is it learns the ideal
center points for the center for the
centroids. Okay? It starts,
it learns these ideal center
points over time. The first,
if they're randomly blue and then it
gets better and better iteratively,
it finds better and better centerpoint's
find the most optimal center point for
the cluster that we're going to
learn. And then it plots it. Okay?
So that's it. Please subscribe for
more programming videos. And for now,
I've got to find my center.
So thanks for watching.